grab your weapon of choice and watch out
for landmines we were joking because we
have the most talked about movie of the
year not really I told my friends I was
gonna see it and they're like didn't
that movie come out eight years ago
[Music]
that's a pretty damn good movie if you
haven't seen it in this video we're
gonna take a deep dive into the hunt and
explore what its cryptic ending says
about our current social political
landscape yay spoil alert for those who
haven't seen it there is a winner at the
end and I'll explain whether it's one of
those damned liberal elites or redneck
conservatives the film begins with a
behind the head shot of Athena played by
Hilary Swank of course we don't know
that it's her until about three quarters
of the way into the movie since her face
is kept hidden from us for literally no
reason and for a film that has a ton of
action its kind of a lackluster start we
get about a minute of just her reading
text messages on her phone and if I
wanted to do that I'd just read the
messages from the teenager had her phone
on in front of me for half the damn
movie Athena is messaging her liberal
elite friends making fun of the
president and joking about how she'd
love to hunt and kill deplorable 'he's
deplorable 'he's of course a nod to
Hillary Clinton's use of the word to
describe Trump supporters in 2016 you
could put half of Trump supporters into
what I call the basket of deplorable
--zz Athena is also sent a photo of a
turtle which I want you to remember for
an important scene that's coming up we
fast forward a year later on a private
jet where we meet Richard which is a
fitting name since he's a dick
pretentiously showing off to the
stewardess how he regularly dines on the
most expensive caviar as he's being
poured champagne he tells her the story
of the 1907 high section pain the
world's most expensive which is sucked
by a German u-boat while being delivered
to Russia in World War one this
champagne is symbol of the liberal elite
will come into play later on in the film
but before the flight lands one of the
deplorable --zz crashes the party yes
the elites have drugged and transported
12 deplorable --zz to a remote location
so they can systematically hunt them
down one of them is played by Emma
Roberts and I kid you not her name is
yoga pants now when I was watching the
trailers for the
movie I thought for sure she'd be one of
the main characters but they did a whole
subvert your expectations thing and kill
her off within the first minute the same
with Staten Island over here played by
Ike Barinholtz their names are
extensions of their characters which are
caricatures in and of themselves
take for example vanilla nice over here
who is some sort of deadbeat gangster
rapper on the elite side many of the
characters are so over-the-top they call
each other out for misgendering and
racial insensitivity while they
themselves are freaking murderers so
yoga pants awakens from her drug-induced
state bound and gagged she immediately
sees this woman crystal in the distance
who uses her nametag to pick the lock on
the back of the gay will later find out
that Krystal is ex-military which is why
she's so good at surviving on her own
and kicking ass they soon come across a
field with a giant crate in the middle
and one of the deplorable --zz named
target you can see why they called him
that opens the crate to reveal a pig
called Orwell named after the author of
Animal Farm Animal Farm tells the story
of a group of farm animals who rebel
against their human farmer hoping to
create a better society which is what
these liberal elites are attempting to
do in fact in a later scene one of the
elites named ma talks about what she's
doing is part of a rebellion the crate
also has other goodies in it pistols
machine guns and a samurai sword for
good measure
yoga pants finds the keys to everyone
gags in an envelope behind the crate
door and just as they start to gear up
they're chased by the elites and picked
off one by one
yoga pants being the first to go
followed by trucker over here three of
the deplorable Czar able to make it over
the fence of this compound that they're
in and into a mom-and-pop gas station
but little do they know the owners are
in on it killing the three by poisoning
them we learn a little bit about MA and
pas who hate those who don't believe in
climate change so it's kind of ironic
they run a gas station and kill their
victims via poisonous gas now it's been
over 20 minutes into the movie and
everyone we thought would be our main
character have all gone up and died
enter Krystle who will take up the
mantle she's able to do that the owners
are not who they say they are when she
asked for a pack of smokes and the price
she is given is way off from what it
should be in Arkansas where pop says she
is she makes quick work of them ready to
escape in a nearby truck only to find it
rigged with explosives she rips off the
Arkansas license plate to reveal
find it a Croatian license plate they
aren't in Arkansas they're in Europe she
has to duck for cover when a drone comes
along looking for her but a deplorable
named Greg shoots it down the two team
up and we learned that Greg is a
right-wing conspiracy theorist this is a
guy who spends his time propagating lies
and is likely a character of Alex Jones
I don't like a button chemicals in the
water
so it's no wonder why the elites chose
him for the hunt in fact part of the fun
of the movie is figuring out why each of
these characters were chosen and the
film gives small clues for each of them
for example big red is an anti LGBT
protester and Staten Island over here is
a douchey gun owner from New York Greg
starts spewing his conspiracy theories
about how liberal elites embedded in the
deep state hunt humans when they hop
aboard a train and find a group of
refugees which Greg immediately calls
crisis actors now one of them is
actually an elite in disguise but it's
never really expanded on how he got on
the train or how he knew that Greg and
Krystal were gonna be there the train
suddenly stops and is inspected by
Croatian military where Greg and Krystal
are taken in as refugees but Greg runs
paranoid into the forest the Croatians
find out that Krystal is indeed American
and unite her with one of the other
hunted named dawn who is this army vet
racist guy but the Croatians are likely
in league with the elites as the Envoy
who comes to pick them up and take them
to the American Embassy is actually one
of them in fact his name on IMDB is foe
envoi or fake envoy translated from
French crystals spider senses go off
when fake envoy over here starts asking
dawn about why these guys chose him of
all people
what he's getting at is that these
people weren't chosen at random there
must have been a purpose later on the
movie will find out that part of this
purpose was to expose their biases maybe
if they see how bad they've been they'll
learn to change Krystal kills the fake
envoy by running him over and in a nice
little roadside chat next to his dead
body tells dawn about a childhood story
her mother used to tell her this story
is similar to that of The Tortoise and
the hare
but in this version after the hare loses
it shows up to the tortoises house
murders him and his family and proceeds
to eat his food because according to her
mother the hare always wins no
what Don asks are we the tortoise or the
hare but she doesn't answer we'll get to
that in a bit crystal and Don take
matters into their own hands and take
the fight back to the elites who are all
holed up in a bunker crystal making
quick work of the group but there is one
elite left the head honcho Athena she
comes on the radio not knowing what has
just transpired and asked Don if he's
killed her yet meaning crystal but is
this just a ploy is he really an elite
or is she playing with crystals mind
anyway she shoots him and goes on one
last mission of a wrench to take on
Athena herself
Athena of course a warrior goddess from
Greek mythology but before we head to
the final confrontation we get a quick
backstory on why these elites set up the
hunt in the first place Athena for
example called the president a rat
[ __ ] and laughed about hunting
deplorable for sport this rumor then
spread around the internet resulting in
her being fired
so she teams up with a group of others
who equally hate these deplorable --zz
each of them with their own reasons like
monpa who can't stand climate change
deniers these guys spent an entire year
creating a list of 12 candidates to be
taken to the hunt each of them a mix of
racist bigoted misogynist climate change
denier pro-gun all the things those on
the Left liked to say about those on the
right Athena believes America now
belongs to the ignorant and uneducated
and all she's doing is culling the worst
of the worst
Cristal was chosen by Athena for a very
personal reason she was the one to post
online that Athena ran a manner where
she hunted humans so what does a thena
do in retaliation start a manner where
people can hunt humans
Athena goes on to tell Cristal that she
knows everything about her how her
parents were meth heads and dealt drugs
but what Athena doesn't know is that she
got the wrong crystal there's a crystal
in her town with the same exact name but
one letter off she even says she
sometimes gets her mail but Athena
thinks she's lying and they engage in
hand-to-hand combat for about 10 minutes
seriously it's a long battle ultimately
both women succumb to stab wounds and
fall on the ground on the verge of death
crystal a Safina while she continually
called her snowball the name of a
character from Animal Farm who was seen
as an idealist but Athena is more
shocked that she actually has read
Animal Farm part of what this movie
tries to shed light on is that sometimes
our assumptions about others aren't what
we think as writer Damon Lindelof said
the movie tries not to get too caught up
and
what their beliefs are because it's so
interested in this idea of identity
politics and and what we assume about
each other and how those assumptions are
very often both dead wrong and dead
right
pun intended crystal ends up surviving
and eating the grilled cheese Athena had
been preparing while they chatted
crystal is the rabbit from her mother's
story even eating the food The Tortoise
Athena in this case made she gets on a
private jet which is conveniently
waiting in the backyard of the manor and
tells the pilot to take her home and in
a fun turn she offers the flight
attendant some caviar which dick didn't
do at the beginning while she sips on
that expensive u-boat champagne she
moved from Athena's Cristal survival is
because she's not on the left or on the
right we actually never get to know her
political views at all she's stuck in
the middle of a war between two equally
crazy sides if the film is trying to say
anything about our polarizing times it's
that both sides are bad perhaps when
you're somewhere in the middle you may
just survive it thanks for watching
everyone please make sure to give the
video a like and subscribe if you watch
the movie I'd also like to hear your
comments below you can also reach out to
me on Twitter acting story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much